it's almost exactly 34 years since the
worst ever terror attack over British
soil a 31 000 feet half an hour into its
flight from Heathrow to New York Pan Am
103 exploded over the town of Lockerbie
citizens from 21 countries were killed
now a new twist in the Quest for justice
his name is Masood for many years
believed to be the man who had made the
suitcase bomb last seen here in this
Libyan jail in 2015 he is now in
American custody but the where when how
we do not know I can only assume that
money or armaments or something's been
done here pleasure's been applied and
Masood will know and almost certainly
face Trail but uh he has been in the
frame as the bomber from the very outset
because mcgrahi never had the capability
of doing the bomb uh he was a minor
player but he was involved Masood was
the main man the technician and to some
extent Justice is being done
it was in 2020 that the Americans made
clear that they wanted him
according to the criminal complaint
affidavit
massoud
built the bomb
that destroyed Pan Am 103.
this is the affidavit the American
justification for their case it's based
on a confession that Masood is said to
have given to a Libyan official in 2012
over 26 Pages it details how he
allegedly took the suitcase bomb to
Malta armed it passed it to an
accomplice who put it on a flight to
Frankfurt and on to London
it was it's long been claimed all part
of a Libyan plot to avenge the American
bombing of Libya in 1986. but other
narratives have festered the one man to
have been convicted Abu basid al-magrahi
failed twice to overturn his conviction
his lawyer says this development could
well undermine the American case you
know how the ridiculous situation that
you have the United States that
prosecuted the case alongside the UK
government alongside the Scottish
authorities against Abdul Assad
Bassett magrahi stating that he was the
man who bought the clothes put them onto
a Samsonite suitcase who knows some 34
years later are saying actually no it
was a man called Masood who brought the
clothes and put them onto a bomb you
can't have one or the other another
twist too it's claimed that Masood was
abducted from custody in Libya a month
ago was a deal done a transfer of a
wanted man but for what all the U.S
authorities will say for now is that he
will be in court in America soon